قد يكونوا من العادي ربما ان تعقب اعماله
شغب نهايه مباراه كره قدم لكن ان تكون
اعماله الشغب هذه سببا في الكشف عن جريمه
بشعه فهنا الصدمه التي هزت محافظه بنزرت
مشجعوها الفريق المحلي يرمون قوات الامن
بجرار فخاريه ومزهريات على بعض الاسطح في
مدينه بنزرت احدها لم تكن تحفي زهورا بل
خمسه اجنه غير مكتمله النمو
لتضج مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بالخبر وتعم
الصدمه الاهاليه
الى مسرح الجريمه وتعاين ما حدث ليتم بعد
ذلك ايقاف طبيب ثمانينيه كانت جثث الاجنه
فوق سطح عيادته يتم اداعه السجن في انتظار
استكمال التحقيقات والتحليل الجنيه
وهذيك
ونقول لي اسمها كبير عنده عامين في الحبس
وبعدها صدمه يبقى مسرح الجريمه شاهدا على
فضاعه ما حدث هنا وليبقى السؤال قائما
ايضا حول الدوافع والاسباب التي تؤدي الى
حدوث مثل هذه الجرائم
التونسيه لكنها في المقابل كشفت وفق
المختصين عن عمق ازمه الاخلاقيه في
المجتمع وانهيار منظومه قيمه سابقه وعدم
الوصول الى اخرى جديده رديت البشريه
والروح البشريه كل شيء محل يعني
يمكن ان يضحي به من اجل احيانا يعني اشياء
ماديه ماديه محدوده حجم الازمه اللي
وصلناها هو كوننا اليوم نحتاج الى عقد
اجتماع جديد نحن مازلنا في اطار البحث عنه
وتعيش وتونس على وقع تحولات اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه يرى المراقبون انها تقتضي بناء
عقد اجتماعيا جديد لتجاوز مخاطرها مستقبلا
من محافظه بنزرت شمال تونس وليد عبد الله
العربيه